Don Jr is here what's up
um what's happening guys what's going on
welcome to the show I think again can
everybody hear you yeah
you can hear me okay yeah yeah so uh
they indicted you're dead what's
happening
what's happening is uh countries
devolved far further than we could have
ever possibly imagined I mean uh this is
a third world stuff uh stuff that the
federal government who actually oversees
elections and spent six years trying to
throw my father in prison for it decided
not to pursue but a Soros funded D.A
apparently uh I guess it's you know
following his marching orders and doing
what he's told and you know what they
paid for his election to do
so we we asked Ian Ian's kind of a wild
card when it comes to politics because
he's not he's not in the same space we
are he's he often he says he wants to
pardon people like Hillary Clinton but
he says it's not moving him like you
you're saying it's like it's not turning
you off from from Trump no it's not but
Dom what's your vision of the future
listen I need I think you need someone
to go burn it all down yes you know
Trump trump is a lame duck uh is
actually much better than someone that
has to get reelected again and has to
play that game I want someone who will
go in there and literally Burn It To The
Ground because it needs to be that like
I used to believe guys like you know
even when I got into this I functioned
at a high level
s and we did build
you know real and uh you know I got
there I was like well listen this is
what America is and I I believe this and
I'm a patriot and I'm like oh my God
even you know once I went through what I
went through with Russia Russia Russia
you know 50 hours of testimony and Adam
Schiff up there saying I committed
treason somehow and then I see you know
of course nothing happens with that of
course none of that was actually
accurate it was all a perjury trap
hoping that in 50 hours of testimony
asking me the same you know a thousand
questions maybe I say it a little bit
differently the the 50th time I'm asked
and therefore I committed perjury and
that's how they get you uh but even even
I who sort of had my eyes open during
that were like well there's still
something to it right we all made the
same mistake with with the FBI and what
they tried to do to Michael Flynn it's
like well it's the FBI so there must be
some truth to it right they're not fully
corrupted it's the FBI the CIA same
thing well so let's you know we're
seeing them go after parents and this
those people are domestic terrorists a
concerned parent going to a PTA meeting
uh but you know some you know trans
shooter can have a Manifesto and kill a
bunch of Christian kids and well that's
not domestic terrorists because they're
Christians like who really gives a
you know that it's it's really scary
where we're at well so so you know let
me just want to burn it to the ground so
but when you say that like what's the
what's the Practical step is that uh
what was that policy that your uh that
Trump senior he's gonna file
when you say that is that what you were
meaning like we're gonna go and we're
going to defund the FBI we're going to
fire all the bureaucrats
yes I mean I mean you got to do as much
as you possibly can you got to get other
people who are willing to go along with
that because I mean I think that's what
you know in 16 we're like Hey we're
coming in from the outside you sort of
assume that you know hey you may have a
little bit differences in policy and
whatever but you know people still want
the best for America and that's just not
even remotely true uh you know these
bureaucrats they wouldn't they wouldn't
succeed in so many other things and
they're going to hold on to what little
power they have because they wouldn't
get it anywhere else uh you see that uh
what's going on you know in our military
and you know the the woke nonsense I'm
like the decision-making process the
withdrawal from Afghanistan uh
everything that's gone I mean like they
couldn't have seen it coming I mean this
I'm like you couldn't have seen it
coming you were there for 20 years what
do you mean you couldn't have seen it
coming like I saw it coming and I don't
know anything about Afghanistan like uh
my nine-year-old son I was picking up
from from school that week and he was
like Hey Dad like why would we leave 86
billion in equipment there I don't
understand dad why would we pull out our
soldiers before the people that have
been helping us for 20 years I like I
was like I felt like an idiot because I
did I was trying to explain to a
nine-year-old that yeah no these people
are just they're that they're that far
gone it's on purpose yeah the word is
surrender that was a surrender in
Afghanistan to the Taliban yes it's and
that should be the word I mean they're
putting up videos of all the equipment
you know they have the second largest
Fleet of Humvees in the world thanks to
us for you know you know in Minor
Details 86 billion that's like 275
dollars per you know man woman and child
in America like I just that was that's
your contribution to the Taliban who our
secretary of state Anthony blinken said
uh like on live TV like in a
congressional testimony that he was and
I quote docked and dismayed that the
Taliban did not install a more diverse
and inclusive government like like
really like you're you're shocked like
you may be dismayed I understand that
like but you're shocked after dealing
with them for 20 years after watching
them throw you know homosexuals off of
buildings and put you know journalists
in a cage douse them in gas and light
them on fire like you're shocked that
there wasn't like a trans Coalition in
the new Taliban government like you're
not a serious person if you think that
well you have no business making
decisions for our country I think these
people are they're they're our Cults
they live in this obnoxious internet
world that's outside of reality they and
and
where they're they're leading us
straight off a cliff you know what
concerns me Don about like the metaphor
of like burn it all down is that when
you do rapid transformation of political
systems uh the solution might not be
like trying to solve one problem might
create a bigger problem like what we did
in Iraq when we dismissed the bath party
we created Isis we put all these
high-level officials on the street and
then they formed their own paramilitary
basically and and I think that our
governments it is evolving we are
becoming a global Community regardless
if we want to do it or we're just going
to put our fingers in our ears and yell
until it happens to us so I I think we
can I think we can bring people together
with like a a vision of Industry you
know graphene I'm not sure how familiar
all right come on but it's like a
revolutionizing 21st century technology
well let me let me let me redirect this
in a way not to be I'm not trying to be
distracted Ian but I'll put it this I go
off on tangents I don't blame you Tim
what I what I saw uh don with your dad
and the reason I didn't vote for him in
2016 I voted in 2020 for for uh for
Trump senior because the foreign policy
I thought thought was the best I've seen
in my entire life when when he crossed
and crossed the DMZ into North Korea
with no security detail I nearly cried
and I'm like it was it was a tremendous
powerful move where they could have just
snatched up the president United States
but it was a tremendous good faith
effort to try and de-escalate this war
has been going on for jet for
Generations I saw all of that foreign
policy and I said wow this is amazing
getting our troops out of Syria and they
lied to him and to us and then I saw
well they're packing Somalia by the way
he took off 500 that we had stations out
there and now they put 600 right back in
because in Syria again that's that's no
well that was Somalia but Syria as well
right I mean I had Joe Kent on my
podcast yesterday whose wife died in
Syria as a result of an ISIS attack and
it's like I do this I was like wait a
minute we have people in Syria still
he's like yeah they're back like I'm
like oh my God they did that without us
even knowing and like I do this you know
like I'm I I'm not necessarily a foreign
policy expert but I'm talking politics
day in and day out and until I had I
guess it was Matt Gates on my podcast
like three weeks ago because he
introduced the bill to try to get us out
of that of course that was voted down
because you know the the uni party in DC
you know they need the endless Wars
that's their retirement plan you get the
board the seat on Raytheon and uh you
know that's how they get out of these
things and so it's it's truly scary yeah
the foreign policy thing was everything
and that's why I'm like when I'm
watching uh you know obviously getting
out of the wars and you know the North
Korea stuff was great and big but the
worst was the reaction from the uni
party Trump's doing it all wrong
remember at the time he's doing it all
wrong I go well what have you guys
accomplished in you know 40 years of
dealing with this problem like have you
had even a meeting like with no you
can't meet with them I'm like well how
are you you've been doing it for 40
years you've accomplished exactly
nothing you have no track record to show
any level of success and you're telling
someone else who actually tried changing
up the game that they're doing it all
wrong and turns out they were right but
that's what's what's really scary is you
know while that's a big deal and that
was Obama told my father correctly that
you know hey North Korea is the biggest
threat but you know right now the
biggest threat is like you know what's
going on in Russia and Ukraine with an
army that we're fighting a proxy war
against with plenty of bitterness from a
cold war and the mentality that changed
and you know in Eastern European
mentality is what she'll say very
different uh than certainly the
mentality of uh Americans these days and
you get you piss off someone with 6 000
nuclear warheads because we're fighting
a proxy war against them and like they
just want to continue they're going to
see it through to the end I'm like for
what gains yeah well for what now we're
talking about the uni party here and
um you know you kind of hit on it a
little bit earlier but one of the the
critiques that I hear sometimes from
from some folks is that there are bad
hires in the Trump admin and and you
talked about that when when you first
started talking about this a little bit
um but but you know you're new to
politics 2016. president Trump was new
to politics you guys come from New York
uh and you know the business world and
you know you I probably just assumed
like a lot of us assume that anybody
that had an r in front of their name was
on our team and they wanted the same
things that we did and uh I think it's
safe to say that seven years later you
guys know that that's very different so
uh do you think you guys know who the
friends are now
I I said it earlier right it's sort of
that you make that assumption that some
of these people they're doing it for all
the right reasons and they're patriotic
Americans and they're not like you know
DC uh you know is a collection of some
of the worst uh we have to offer as far
as I'm concerned and that's on both
sides that's a that's a uh you know
bipartisan uh deal and uh but you know
again they don't have much going for
them they probably couldn't do a lot in
a lot of these places I've spent plenty
of time with a lot of them and uh you
know you wouldn't hire them to be you
know a basic guy in business and yet
they have a level of power uh and the
money that comes with that and that and
they ain't letting it go you know the
swamp has a lot of teeth and you you
come in as an outsider and you're like
okay like of course these guys want
what's right for America well you know
we could buy a little bit of that off
this is the crazy thing it's just so
different than you think so I think you
know now you have an understanding of
that and you just gotta you gotta go in
with that understanding it's so
different uh and again you know we were
he was effective meeting my father
at so many things whether it's
economically foreign policy wise or
otherwise and that's with both sides
working against him uh I mean how many
Republicans you know Paul Ryan like we
we're not right we can't we're not going
to build the wall you know I can't fund
that I want to you know my wife said art
and liberal and uh she you know she
wants to still be invited to the cool
person holiday party so we didn't have
three billion dollars to finish the wall
but we have 130 for Ukraine to protect
uh you know one of the most corrupt
countries in the world meaning Ukraine
ranked worse than Russia in many
instances uh we have 130 billion dollars
to protect their border it's it's Lunas
the crazy thing is I'm asking when I was
at Occupy Wall Street and even before
that with the anti-war movement when you
said a moment ago the Raytheon
retirement package I'm like that that
right there was such a big issue for all
of the left 12 years ago I'm like where
are they now to just be like hey we've
got a handful of Victories with Donald
Trump we should take those over the
corrupt uniparty Joe Biden instead it's
like their brains melted and they're
just like I'll vote blue no matter who
even if it means more war and now on the
brink of World War III with Ukraine it's
like the anti-war movement turns to Mush
they're scared they're very serious and
that's not a never-ending War I mean
that's like a perhaps a world-ending war
yeah right you know we could get bogged
out in the Middle East forever it's you
know maybe there's some terrorist
attacks I'm not I'm not belittling that
or but like
you know those guys wouldn't have the
ability to literally end the world
Russia has 6 000 nuclear warheads like
think about that for a second and you
think that a a
megalomaniac like a Putin and again I'm
not apologizing for him when I when I
don't want to be in these things but
like you don't think a guy like that who
many are saying well he's he's very sick
and he's like you think that guys could
allow Ukraine and actor zielinski to
embarrass him on a world stage without
escalating like no way agreed yeah when
you asked earlier you asked earlier Don
what is it for why are we spending
hundreds or over 100 billion for to
fight a proxy war against uh I think
it's because the the people that are
running the liberal economic order want
to position it above Russia in the New
World Order and they think that stopping
Russia from Gaining economic prowess
with that black seaport access and
Sebastopol will will win us the
greatness in the New World Order and
then we'll decide the rules but what's
happening is it's pushing Russia and
China together exactly the opposite I
mean you know they were going gonna shut
down their currency and meanwhile it's
skyrocketing uh you know we stop our oil
production become dependent on Iran and
Venezuela we didn't recognize and the
world's leading State sponsor of Terror
and like we're begging them for oil
because we shut it down while Russia
continues to pump like it's lunacy the
way to hurt Russia would be for us to
produce more of our own oil Drive the
price of oil down create jobs in America
and like they got nothing else like we
have more than them but you know well
we're not going to do it environmentally
sound you think the Russians you think
they take any environmental precautions
they could care less yeah I think and
China in order to help the United States
like less about hurting Russia more
about helping the United States is is
trade with Russia and it would help us
so much more than it would help them
because of our ability to create here
that it would actually be better and it
would position us and this is what Trump
was basically talking about he sounds
like Trump right I know I think
diplomacy is the answer the Chinese the
Russia Americans need to work together
to protect this planet listen to what
Donald Trump what was the only works
guys if if there's like some force
behind it right that's why Trump they
saw Trump like okay he's not someone to
be trifled with it's the nature of
predation okay I'm gonna Putin is a
bully he is a bully you know even though
they're they're bullies
bullies take advantage of weakness
that's the nature of that game just like
an animal in the wild takes out the
weakest in the herd when they want Phil
Biden on a world stage they're like oh
like we can eat those guys lunch because
it's incompetent you know while Putin is
meeting with a G and while his G is
simultaneously meeting with the Saudis
to get rid of the Petro dollar which
allows the left to have you know the
billions of dollars that they use to
fund trans programs in Pakistan which is
just being stolen by you know people
over there creating an oligarch class
but while that's going on the White
House is hosting the you know the cast
of Ted lasso
shout out to Brandon no it sounds funny
it'd be funny if it was a sitcom but
like man I wake up on some days I'm like
dude I I hope that I'm just like the
star of The Truman Show and that
everyone is just with me because
if they're not it's a disaster hey Don I
know Trump has a long list of
accomplishments I wanted to ask you what
do you think his biggest accomplishment
was and then on the flip side his
biggest shortcoming in his first term
oh
biggest accomplishment I mean I guess it
just look at the the economy was going
so good man you know I guess I I look at
that you know I'm sort of a you know a I
was a blue-collar guy sort of Trapped in
New York but I spent all my weekends
with guys up in North you know northeast
PA and I I shot competitively hung out
with regular guys I'm like watching what
those guys that continue to come up to
me is like man we had it so good under
your dad like that meant more to me I
mean I think obviously the North Korea
stuff when I was just baller uh I think
the Abraham Accords like that was the
Holy Grail of geopolitical politics
right yes like No One's Gonna Get a
peace deal in the Middle East we've been
trying for centuries it's like well we
got five
it was the Holy Grail of geopolitan it
can't be done it can't be well no it
can't be done by you because you're an
imbecile like you're there you're in
power because you were a big donor to
someone not because you've done anything
relative to this you're there because
you're you've been there longer and you
have seniority it's like
ouchy does anyone really believe that
fauci was the best guy in medicine that
he should be making the decision no but
he was the best bureaucrat and I'm sure
as he was really good at snaking
anyone who got in the way of him and a
TV Camera from the 80s through because
it doesn't seem like he got anything
right so he may have gotten some of the
things of covid right in his emails to
his colleagues but that was exactly the
opposite of what he was saying on
national TV because as long as you were
going against Trump you got an extra
camera in your face you got the cover of
Vanity Fair or some you know nonsense
Rag and like that was his currency so so
what do you think Trump's uh as to at
re-ask what I think he's not shortcoming
of Donald I I would I would say you know
it has to be you know on that hiring
front because when you come in as a new
from outside of that world you it takes
a lot like it's hard to overcome Decades
of being like no like if you're gonna do
this and you're you're a public servant
you're doing it for the right reasons
and man it is so wrong it's it's like
what you see in public politics like
some of these people that are running
it's like they have no chance like oh
that you know what it is it's a book
tour absolutely they're running so they
can drum up some numbers for a book tour
or some guys are running because the
Consulting class that we won't hire
needs to have a job and they got to make
their eight or nine figures taking 20 of
the ad buy of someone's campaign and
like they're pushing people like they're
being forced into it because the
Consulting class is like Hey listen if
you guys don't do it we're gonna have to
you know just get by with a
congressional race and we're not going
to make 15 million dollars this like on
the ad buy like yeah it's a screwed up
place man and like people don't fully
understand that I again I dealt at a
pretty high level and I didn't fully
understand it and I certainly didn't
understand how how deep and depraved it
actually is until you know I mean man
every day my eyes are further opened and
you know this this week this week was
sort of the culmination of all of that
right you saw the the the reaction uh to
the to the shooting in Nashville that
and you know it's like you have moments
in your life I guess where it's just
like a a kick to the groin uh you know
the Afghan withdrawal the week after
that to me as an American was one of
those just you just felt embarrassed
absolutely and at one follow-up on his
greatest response to Nashville was like
that to me which is like you know it's
not it's not the Christian children
they're not the victim it's the trans
community and it's literally going
through a genocide I'm like well like
how like I know you say that but like
where like I I don't see that like it's
I'm over a pretty big voice in the
conservative movement and like I have
trans friends it I don't care I draw the
line you wanting to jack up a
three-year-old with hormones without
their parents uh any involvement I think
that's sociopathy but like
I don't know I think I'm pretty you know
let's call it Progressive on the issue
that's not enough and that one follow-up
on his greatest achievement situation
and that's like everything else going on
right now absolutely and I had one
follow-up on his greatest achievements
because I know Trump constantly touts
operation warp speed and he held the
covid-19 vaccine is one of the greatest
achievements of mankind do you agree
with him on that
yeah I I don't you know because of what
we know now I think at the time cutting
through that again you can't fathom that
let a guy like a faucy and the people
developing this would do so in a
nefarious way meaning like it's like
listen I get it I'm a capitalist I
understand profit motive I understand
this that the other yada yada but like
it's people's lives
um you know I think it took all all of
that time and all of those years to
fully just understand how bad it
actually is
um you know again it's easy to be a
Monday Morning Quarterback and say I
would have done it differently but
through it all the people that are
saying that now you see you look at
their social fees I'm like oh really it
sounds like you were playing the exact
same game it's easy to say you would
have done it differently because there's
no way to prove and otherwise but like
your actions at the time it's not like
you called him out no one was doing that
because the media would destroy you
they'd but they'd literally be out there
and say you're you're killing Americans
you're doing this it's you're literally
costing tens of thousands I want to add
to the the the the context of the time
hindsight is 20 20. back when this is
all going on Trump was being cheered for
all of this like this is great good job
we want to see more of it in the early
days the conservatives were in favor of
masks then it flips fauci was saying
don't wear masks so like I think a lot
of what happens when we talk about the
Trump Administration and the past is
it's easy to look now based on all the
facts we have and say that is a bad
decision but I'll put it this way well
the other example and you know it's a
negative to us well I'll give it to you
would be like people's like well you
know the January 6th you know why didn't
you do anything I was like you mean in
the 10 days between January 6 and when
he left office when every TV Camera was
saying it was an Insurrection no one
really knew they didn't show the videos
that we haven't seen until basically two
weeks ago what was really going on like
he was supposed to blanket part and
everyone like I'm like I don't know like
we were told that that was really there
how do you do that now it's easy to say
it now yeah we've seen the video we saw
the nonsense we saw the refusal even a
few weeks later but in that 10-day
period with literally the entire world
being like it was an answer
maybe you had to say well it was the
first unarmed Insurrection in literally
the history of the world which is
probably unusual but like given the
response like so I get it I wanna I
wanna I think ask you wrong but I but I
think I can think it's wrong knowing
what I know now at the time I'm like
holy I don't know like I you know I
thought it was probably overblown but
it wasn't so simple right I wanna I
wanna I wanna talk about 2024 and I want
to just say something real quick on on
DeSantis about a year ago I went on a
daily wire stream and said I was
probably leaning towards DeSantis as it
comes 2024 because he's done such
tremendously good things with with his
leadership in Florida and then as as
time's gone on more importantly as uh as
uh Donald Trump senior has come out with
messaging has started to focus on on
policy and the election it's been a
tremendous Improvement the East
Palestine thing where he shows up he
does the McDonald's thing that that
really does hit hard for me when he's
like I know the menu better than you and
he's buying people McDonald's I love it
I absolutely love it it gives me good
feels and I'm like I like seeing this I
don't see it from anybody else who's
running I like vivekama Swami he didn't
go down there Marin Williams Williamson
seems very nice she didn't go down there
and so especially now with the
indictment I feel like Rhonda Santa
saying we will not be involved is a half
measure he should absolutely say you
will not extradite Donald Trump well
beyond that like that but that's like
that's the second part of it right that
was that's the response this week which
is a half measure last week was much
worse than that which is like well it's
a sideshow that's not real you know it's
made up like you mean it's a sideshow
that you've weaponized you know the the
government against its citizens against
its political oppositions yeah oh that's
a side show you know in stalinist Russia
uh you know that like if you couldn't no
no seriously if you couldn't pick that
out and I understand just like the
flip-flop on Ukraine that he did as well
like you know I get it he he is you know
he's been a career politician he's
beholden to his donors probably his
Consultants but like man like if you
don't realize that is maybe one of the
the fundamental issues of our time if
you're a Republican or a conservative if
that's going on like you think you know
right now I get it the media is doing
whatever they can to boost him because
they're afraid of trump and what Trump
will do again to the uni party like oh
no that's wonderful but Hey Ron like one
day they may come for you and you don't
think it's an issue
I want a deeper Republican bench man I I
I actually believe this stuff like
there's no reason for me to be as vocal
as I am in this I had a pretty solid
existence as a real estate developer uh
in New York City I could go to the cool
person party and I was welcomed in with
open arms and could do whatever I wanted
like uh that's different now and I'm
okay with that because I want to leave
my country to like my children in a in a
foreign
I want to ask you about that to
elaborate on that
um I think it's fair point when when
your dad's taxes finally get released we
learned that he loses a bunch of money
throughout his first term as president
and didn't take a salary and I think
that says a lot I mean you guys are a
very wealthy powerful family I know
celebrities who have when when when your
dad was running in 2016 with all the
negative press who would be like well I
know the trumps they're actually really
nice and good people they're super
generous but you know he's a racist now
I guess and I'm not going to vote for
him I I'm wondering like if you want to
elaborate on the transformation from
like you mentioned going to the Cool
Kids Club then deciding to get involved
in politics and now like the media's
gone nuts and they treat you like trash
yeah listen like I said it was
interesting you know I I it's a lot of
those people all of a sudden you're
right I'm like we're racist like dude we
had dinner last month like what do you
like what like I have your cell phone
number like
we party together like you know when I
was young I'm like so so you think now
like and by the way it's not like I ever
hit by politics I was I was always a
conservative I was a big gun guy I was a
competitive shooter you know so I I had
my you know had my good you know redneck
friends up on you know on the weekends a
lot but I could still be a fixture in
New York it wasn't as much my thing it
was much more like you know my sister
Ivanka like she was it wasn't a woman
you know socialite in New York that
didn't want her daughter to turn out
like Ivanka Trump and all of a sudden
she's like okay I'm gonna go support my
father and they actually didn't get
involved in a lot of the controversial
stuff but like you know what's the bad
for like you know women who work and
it's like oh she's a pariah I'm like so
it was probably harder for her in many
respects than maybe because I was like
okay fine if I don't get invited to the
cool person but I don't care I'll go
hang out with you know sort of my good
Blue Collar friends which it always
meant more to me anyway like that's
probably why Politics the transition
sort of as brutal as it was for me was
kind of easy because it's like well
that's I actually get to be who I
actually am much more
than
than when I was in business I sort of
had to five days a week put on the suit
and you know be be that guy I could do
it I could play the game I get it like
it is a game uh but you know there was a
Friday afternoon I'd escape and I'd be
in you know middle of nowhere
Pennsylvania or Upstate New York and at
my cabin and so you know it was a little
bit easier and it so it didn't bother me
as much because I I guess I just see it
for what it is but yeah like a lot of
those people and you know I'm a good
enough person that's like hey man even
if we're friends like I'm not gonna call
you out on these things I'm not going to
do all of that literally I'm publishing
a book for my father uh right now I you
know all the publishing houses were so
liberal and so uh jaded it's called
letters to Trump because we're going
through some files and I'm like oh my
God like here's a letter from Alec
Baldwin kissing your ass like here's the
letter from like no no Chuck Schumer and
Bill Clinton and Hillary Clinton like
it's it's sort of I mean I see this file
like his assistant did a really good job
just keeping some of this stuff and I
was like oh my God because it just kills
you let me how how much nonsense is
involved and you know I started a
Publishing Company because all the
liberal publishing companies which is
all of them were canceling a lot of
conservative you know writers are
telling them well you can't say that
even if it's just mainstream
conservative thought because they wanted
to impose their power and if they're
writing that upfront check to an author
or whatever it may be they were doing
this I was like I wrote my second book
uh and it was during covet and so I was
like well I had the time at home I was
like we're gonna self-publish this and
try to do it because I saw what the
publishing houses were doing to me and I
had a number one New York Times
bestseller with my first book and but
you start seeing the games being played
I'm like let's try it let's you know
they all say build your own so I was
like let's build our own let me let me
ask you about uh no you know finish that
finish the thought oh go ahead it's all
good but the general point if we had to
combat some of this stuff and uh we I've
tried you know in whichever way we can
just to make sure they have an equal
front because what people don't
understand they're like well you're you
know it feels like it's overwhelming I'm
like yeah it is because we're up against
a trillion dollar big Tech Enterprise
that is just radical left uh you know
social media other than maybe truth
social uh you know heavily heavily
skewed uh to the left just look at the
way they censor and you know and or fact
check uh you have mainstream media
another trillion dollar organization I
mean we are up against a juggernaut and
like we're still doing pretty good
someone someone in the chat asked about
you and your dad's stance on the Second
Amendment foreign
well listen I'm about I mean I shot
200 rounds today
as it gets I mean I shot competitively
for many years I've you know a gun
collector I've spoken at every major you
know gun event out there that uh you
know my father's more of a golfer he
understands the Second Amendment and you
know I I'm not just someone who believes
in the Second Amendment not actually you
know uh an Enthusiast unlike you know so
many of the politicians even the
conservative politicians where you see
them you know they take their obligatory
gun picture and their fingers on the
trigger and they're pointing it in
someone's face and you're like you know
I guess you can believe in the Second
Amendment and not know how to actually
use a gun but you know it probably helps
to have some experience hey hey Don Phil
I want to hear uh I I I want to go back
to something that Iliad had said he he
mentioned um what you what you thought
the the
um sorry about that
um I apologize
a good book I apologize
um but one of the biggest things that my
problem with Donald Trump was was the
you know the swamp the bureaucracy do
you think that that's going to be the
the Prime Focus that if he gets elected
again is to really go in there and tear
it out because I think that that could
really get a lot of them all yeah a lot
of the libertarian people out there that
don't like you know a lot of the big
government stuff
um the New York style politics and stuff
the the Libertarians you gotta remember
that and I get that I I get that so I
mean I think you do have to do because I
don't think you have a choice right the
swamp's not you know if you if you go
easy on the swamp we've seen that no
they're not going to give you it was
like you know my lawyers after after the
stuff for Russia Russia Russia they're
like hey man they're there they want to
try you for treason like you got to take
that seriously you can't be on social
media talking and fighting back
like they want to put you in jail for
life or you know or worse and I'm like
you don't understand like they're not
like if I curl up in a ball and suck my
thumb in the corner crying for mommy
like they're not gonna go any less
they're gonna go harder it's like when
when people do their apology tours and
it's I'm like oh that was a mistake
because a you weren't really wrong but
they're going to use your apology as the
validation for the fact that you
actually did something wrong in the
first place so you're trying to be a
decent human being by apologizing and
just saying hey fine well a degree to
disagree and that's that's just the
starting point for them canceling you
and so you know I think that New York
style politics like I think you need it
because that's what we're up against and
I also think you have again all things
are a little bit about perspective right
like
fine he was right he maybe got rougher
but like they got rougher because
they're trying to throw his family in
jail for nothing we know that like that
that's no fact they're trying to throw
him they impeached him twice for what
growing a great economy and this all
nonsense like you know you have to have
that hard approach if you go soft you
don't get points for going soft I'll
tell you what they don't they don't give
you like okay well fine we're gonna
we're gonna let Trump you know real for
a little bit more oil and gas and boost
the American economy because he's being
friendly and nice that's not how it
works they don't care if they had if
they if they had like a moderate
Democrat in 2016 and throughout 2020 who
was talking about helping the working
class securing our borders like things
Bernie Sanders had talked about in 2015
and they did not lie about literally
everything related to your dad I'd have
I'd have been like well you know I think
I'll still vote Democrat but they're
corrupt if they lied they manipulated
and they didn't care about our country
and so naturally for a while I'm like I
hate everybody then I saw the Trump
second term agenda and I said these are
actually things I've been complaining
about for a long time I'd be a hypocrite
if I didn't vote for it and I think it's
safe to say that President Trump hears
people's concerns these listens and now
he knows I think the first the test
trial for not you know for you guys the
first term you guys did incredibly great
things president Trump had a record
Academy he had energy and dependencies
brokering Middle Eastern peace he was
putting bringing jobs back to America
just wanted to cut the bureaucracy and
and that's the pro that's the part that
he didn't realize like we knew a swap
was there they knew a swap was there but
they didn't know how deep and now
everybody knows how deep and everybody
knows exactly what roles they are
exactly who needs to go and I don't want
to belabor the point but yeah it sort of
like like I said earlier it's like now
that you've had that Insider perspective
like I realized like there's not even a
you know I've been a fly on the wall
I've been in the room and I see the
reporting about it like there's not a
pretense of like objectivity or a
pretensive you know trying to get the
truth out there it's it's just narrative
I think uh and I think everyone else has
seen that now as well I mean I I sort of
did the you know I did a tweet earlier
that went pretty good and it was like
you know it's it's weird like uh all the
people who visited Epstein Island like
no one's been indicted no one's there
English in Maxwell I guess is doing 25
five years of hard time for sex
trafficking minors to no one because
they're going to indict president Trump
with something that's never even been
tried as a felony for a camp a a made-up
campaign Finance violation because the
federal government themselves decided it
wasn't real like that merits an
indictment and their obligatory purple
now I think they also turn them into an
absolute Legend uh when they do this
that's fine I'm okay with that but like
just think of the the juxtaposition I I
use the you know imagine Don Jr did one
of the 500
like degenerate things that Hunter Biden
did like just one like I you know I
understand according to the left I'm not
the upstanding human being that Hunter
Biden is I'm a terrible guy but like I
don't know I imagine I did one of those
things whether and again I don't even
I'm not even talking about the money
stuff I'm talking about the hookers and
the crack and the you know and
videotaping all of it imagine what
Hunter decided it's like hey you know
this is a bit too much of a video
imagine what else is out there and by
the way imagine how many of our enemies
probably know what else is out there and
I wonder if we're being played no no
seriously like it seems like everyone
has a hunter Biden laptop you don't
think the Chinese they give him one
billion dollars do you think the Chinese
give a billion dollars to your average
crackhead no they don't unless they're
buying you I wanted to say you think the
Ukraine does the same thing no I wanted
so we're spending 130 billion in a
country that we don't know and no one's
even bothering to ask hey do you think
our decision-making process is Jaded by
what they may have on on the bidens like
I know if it was Don Jr they'd be asking
the question I'd be in jail I wanted to
say on the point about firing all the
bureaucrats I actually I believe that if
if Donald Trump is re-elected if he gets
a second term in the 2024 election and
wins a large portion of these people
will quit resign and they will run for
the hills that would be so Good by the
way that would be the greatest thing in
the world to happen and that's the
reality if you had eight years you have
some of that natural attrition it's a
long time well that's after 25 more of
most people's careers uh you got to do
that but yes I think if they realize
that someone's just going on there and
they don't care and they don't have to
get reelected and they don't have to
make friends and frankly they've been
treated so poorly that they don't they
don't care about any of that like I I
think literally like that's that's what
I'd be voting for I don't care whoever
if it was going on for someone else and
they were doing the same thing to
someone else you know sometime down the
line I was like I'm voting for that guy
just because I want to see that place
just you know taken down to the bones I
do think that if if he wins again I do
believe he will a lot of these people
will quit out of protest and the swamp
will start dreading itself fear so
there's no fear and call it a protest
absolutely but you know after the 2020
election there was a moment in time
where a guy named Jeffrey Clark was
almost appointed to be the attorney
general and you've had him on your show
before yeah yeah and
hundreds of people at the Department of
Justice said if Jeffrey Clark becomes
the AG we'll quit and now we just had to
find out we found out exactly what we
need to do to get I don't know anything
about his balance his politics but I'd
be like hey he's
the drain itself the doj all you have to
do is point a point Jeff Clark as AG so
do we have a solution to that one
um but you know all of these different
bureaucrats and all these different
agencies I think we got to move a lot of
these people out of Washington DC put
them in real America
um and they'll quit and protest out of
that as well but
um we're really looking forward to a
second truck term because you guys know
where the the bodies are buried you know
who needs to go and uh I don't think
that you gotta hold any punches because
uh I think he has been treated
incredibly unfairly you know what the
metaphor I want I want is with it's like
Donald's Donald Trump your dad Don
senior is like on his knees and they're
like they're like being metaphorically
you know in the movie and he's like his
face is all bloody knees down he looks
up at the guy and looks him in the eyes
and he says you're pardoned
because that's the christ-like thing to
do I think it might not be the battle
strategy tactic but I think that that
will it'll just resonate on the other
side of this one I want him to go in
with a bunch of guys dude I want him to
go with federal law enforcement and be
like you're all under arrest yes I don't
my perspective has changed because of
what I saw they tried to do to me like
literally you know I had you know Adam
Schiff and you know some of those guys
like on TV every I committed treason
like I'm a patriotic American man I take
that seriously you know beyond the
fact that it's you know a crime
punishable by death like you're just
saying like I'm I'm not Amer Adam shifts
in America like give me a break like uh
I you know so yeah I'm coming at it from
a much more uh pissed off perspective
um but you know again you look at just
what's going on you look at the
decisions you look at the prioritization
you look at the Sound by everything
that's coming it is a clown show do you
think that we could like clown show you
listen to the press secretary and it's
like you know and I I I got all sorts of
hell look at John fetterman you know
Pennsylvania you know senator they
they've called me I'm every name in the
I'm an ableist apparently I discriminate
against people with disabilities because
I've been like you know calling him out
for not being able to complete a thought
or a sentence and then he's and I'm like
I don't think it's an unreasonable
expectation guys not for a senator no
for an American to assume that his
Senator a person making trillion dollar
decisions perhaps life and death
decision sending our kids to war
especially when dividing the
administration is saying we're the
closest we've been since the 1960s in
the Cuban Missile Crisis like I don't
think it's an unreasonable thing for me
to expect a United States Senator to
have basic cognitive function and if you
look at that guy that's like the minimum
standard that's why he's been in a
hospital for a month he spent more time
in a hospital but they knew that when
they ran him in a primary but he was the
most radical so they let him get through
it they're saying oh you're a terrible
person for doing this he's stressed out
already he was stressed out before and
you ran him for Senate okay like I'm not
the bad guy here folks you can say what
you want I'm not gonna apologize I'm not
gonna withdraw my commentary I think
it'd be wonderful if he was a bad guy at
Walmart that's one great gainful
employment is important everyone should
have it John Spiderman has no business
being a United States Senator exactly it
doesn't take a brilliant person to
figure this out but oh man they went
after me I'm the most discriminatory
person in the world for expecting the
guy to be able to you know
hi thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time